is the adult movie star who says she had
an affair with them businessman Donald
Trump in danger
her lawyer says so insisting she has
been physically threatened and he's
promising that stormy Daniels will
provide details that prompted a
reluctant response from the Trump
administration this afternoon
of course mounting Kevin cork is at the
White House tonight with that story and
more good evening Kevin good evening
Brett I freely acknowledge a great
number of Americans don't want to hear
more about the stormy Daniels
controversy but today even the White
House couldn't help but weigh in on the
latest twist in this wince-inducing
drama try though they might to steer
clear of the subject
White House officials were again today
forced to wait into the latest
controversy surrounding adult film
performers stormy Daniels whose attorney
claimed was physically threatened to
keep quiet about her alleged
relationship with in private citizen
Trump obviously we take the safety and
security of any person seriously
certainly would condemn it anyone
threatening any individual but I have no
knowledge of that situation and would
refer you to the president's outside
personal attorneys but Daniel's attorney
today promised the world would know more
about the alleged threat soon I'm not
alleging anything I'm stating a fact and
the fact is that my client was
physically threatened to stay silent
about what she knew about Donald Trump
the details surrounding that she's going
to discuss I'm sure on the 60 Minutes
interview on March 25 the Daniel's
controversy a relative dusting compared
to the blizzard of news surrounding the
potential departure of the president's
national security adviser HR McMaster
today the White House push back against
that narrative the president said that
was not accurate and he had no intention
of changing that they had a great
working relationship and he looked
forward to continue working with it for
now McMaster remains on the job but
joining him as a member of the cabinet
could prove challenging for the
president's nominee to head the CIA
Gina Haspel who more than a decade ago
reportedly oversaw an infamous CIA
secret prison in Thailand where
terrorism suspects were waterboarded
we're high
confident and certainly very excited
about the nomination of deputy directors
you know house well to take over at the
CIA she is an incredibly qualified she's
someone who has been in the CIA for over
thirty years has a respect of both
Republicans and Democrats Haspel by the
way got to that post well after the
waterboarding took place as as far as we
can tell from our reporting by the way
Rand Paul the senator from Kentucky has
come out against her nomination but
today the White House pushed back on
that saying that his criticism of her
record was less than serious right Kevin
core clapping the North Lawn Kevin thank
you